hey everyone I'm Alana we're here at
Gamescom day 2 and it is ridiculously
busy and i'm just about to play the sims
4 i do actually have a creative some
demo video here on my channel but i'm
actually just about to play build mode
and the actual free mode so let's go
check it out so i got to create a sim
and then create an actual house and get
her a job and all that fancy stuff
biggest difference that i did notice and
the thing that I guess the sims have
been advertising a lot is the difference
in build mode which is way instead of
drawing a sort of shape with a wall tool
like you do to the previous sims you
know sort of put a room down and then
stretch it and drag it to size but
luckily I did get to talk to someone who
can explain it a little bit better than
I can
next we right now is August who is a
producer on the sim school so i actually
just had a hands-on with the game and
its really really well made everything
is really polished but i tell you what's
actually knew in the sims 4 yeah so in
the sims 4 we have all new emotions and
new relatable behavioral Sims who like
are more believable than ever before
it's actually important after room while
I was blue sounds like I want to do
while Jerry when you just pay a certain
amount of money to import a 30 so this
stuff like that like specific rooms are
already fully furnished will players be
unemployed yeah absolutely so we have a
set amount of style rooms that come with
the base game but players could also
create these rooms and upload them to
the gallery that other players have any
download so it's really great is there a
maximum to the Geller like how help you
guys women wow that's crazy yeah so I
didn't actually get to play it for that
long but I did make a glutton it my sim
that was insane got hungry yeah what
would happen already um so glutton sims
are less picky about food so you can eat
something that's spoil and they really
won't care if they're like oh it's
delicious oh my mother's sake No exactly
other sim so like if you've got a booty
sim they're gonna hate it they're gonna
have a bad time that's probably gonna
[ __ ] your sense of motion to being
unpleasant or upset or stressed one of
those so wearing the previous seems
there's kind of traits late for what
they enjoy this can also
one who makes them upset I make Sam
angry exactly yeah our new emotional
content is so far reaching in the
staticky so the selecting of traits in
this game actually affects your since
behavior like the way they interact with
other sims the way they interact with
the environment and the way they feel so
those emotions really come out based on
how your Sims traits are would you think
it's harder to manage that if they have
no strength to change different things
not really because the player stuff has
control over this engine ocean ok so how
their traits that will conclude with
each other like if one person is
charismatic than the other one is a
wonderful way to automatically don't get
along it's funny because there are
interesting stories that you can tell
that way like for example if you have a
good and evil in people Sam which is in
the same household it's just kind of
interesting because the story that that
tells is kind of surprising so sometimes
they might be on good terms or sometimes
like the syndics people will be happy
because they're causing misery to the
other sim but other times the evil soon
will be happy because the good sim does
something nice for I don't know it's
really interesting sorry basically every
single time he plays only have different
trades it'll be completely different
yeah it's a new experience every time
one thing I have to ask about yeah
toddlers have been taken out of the game
yeah so all of the teaching toddlers to
walk in teaching them to
I think be crazy to do so has that
something replaced why a different stage
so what we did is we're still or we
built on the solid foundation for the
base game so we really wanted to pin
down the things that will make the game
you know expandable right now we don't
have toddlers but you know it's it's
something that we noticed and there's
only so much time that we can put into
the base game we want to make sure it's
a really solid foundation first and you
know that's do you have any plans for
future expansion so far um we're still
talking about and we're still discussing
it nothing solid yet but um yeah thnkx
can obviously or anything about
nightlife that was even on the streets
to actually something dude be cool see
that stuff again yeah absolutely so
obviously the same sports probably to be
maybe a lot of content to be a lot of
community focus stuff what are you most
see when 640 I am most looking forward
to seeing what people actually upload to
the gallery because we've already seen
some really fantastic creations with
josh demo right now I can't wait till
players get the full experience oh thank
you very much chef thank you